following on from april kelleher
and aurelio diaz's stories we have ike
ronson
an shd agent turned rogue
while many think of rogue agents as bad
the enemy and evil to the core
there are stories like ikes that offer a
different perspective on these agents
and why some of these agents ended up
turning their back on the division
[Music]
situated in long island agent ike
cronson received a call from mantis
checking to make sure isaac isn't
monitoring the call he tells her to go
ahead
mantis informs ike of a civilian holding
valuable intel who is leaving manhattan
he is to follow and observe she's a
white female in her early 30s
red brown hair blue eyes and
approximately five foot seven
her name april kalahar it is believed
that she may be on her way to ann arbor
ike confirmed the instructions and
signed off to report back in 48 hours
if he was to catch up with her he needed
to depart immediately
but he was currently in the middle of a
jtf operation to retake city hall
his part in this was to watch the flank
and alert the main force if neighboring
gangs were to join the attack
he didn't want to leave the jtf and his
fellow division agents to be ambushed
he came up with a plan to grab the
attention of the gang he was watching
and draw their attention onto him where
he could lead them away and eventually
lose them
after emptying a couple of magazines
into a group of them he disappeared
through one of the back doors of the
building he'd been hiding in
he could hear the shouting and the
return fire coming from the rest of the
gang
who'd been alerted by his initial bursts
but he wasn't concerned
these were just street thugs with all
his training he shouldn't have any
trouble losing them
but while running through the corridors
he came across a group of civilians
at least a dozen of them consisting
mainly of children
he could hear the gang members coming
but he certainly didn't have enough
firepower and ammunition to hold them
off
he needed to be leaving the city to
catch up with april but he couldn't just
leave the civilians to be gunned down by
the gang
spotting a fire exit he screamed at
civilians to go
but before they were able to make it
very far they were showered in broken
glass
the gang had predicted the direction he
would take some of the civilians were
armed
and charged through the door at the
attackers turning back at the direction
he'd come from
ike lobbed a couple of grenades down the
hall to put a stop to the hostiles who'd
been following him
he walked down the hall to clear anyone
remaining and made it to the street
where he started making his way south
but not before he called him the
incident
saying civilians were under fire and
needed support
ike managed to board a jtf patrol boat
which would take him to the other side
of the river
no questions asked due to his division
status
once back on land ike was briefed by a
young jtf officer
on what had been happening in the area a
group of terrorists have been planning
to blow up a bridge
that was being used by the jtf as a
supply line
ike needed to leave and make his way to
ann arbor but this kid looked to be no
older than 18
and well out of his depth plus the
counter measures that mantis had put in
place to stop isaac marking him his
rogue would only go so far
he still needed isaac to provide his
heads-up display if he didn't assist on
a job like this
questions would start being asked he
queried of their approximate whereabouts
and requested a few supplies he would
need for the mission
making his way into the surrounding
forest area it wasn't long before he was
able to locate the group
using a night vision scope he was able
to observe them and get an idea of what
he was up against
six tenths 13 people all white
all male many of them armed with jtf
issue weapons
although director 51 didn't require him
to confirm anything
if anything he could just walk up and
blast down the lot of them but this
wasn't the sort of person he was
it was at this time that he reflected on
what had happened in manhattan
he hoped that another agent had picked
up his distress call and managed to save
the civilians
however he had a situation in front of
them that was fairly clear-cut
this was a group who'd attacked a jt of
patrol and stalled in a pile of c4
of which they were planning on
destroying supply lines of aid being
brought into the city
from the cover of darkness ike prepared
to strike the group of terrorists
before the first grenade hit the ground
he was throwing the next
among the explosions he was popping off
shots to any able bodies who were able
to stand up
when everything looked clear he made his
way down to the tents
cautiously walking through ike found the
c4
more than enough to blow up a bridge but
then
approaching another tent he heard the
cry of a baby
its mother had been killed by the
shrapnel from one of his grenades
although less than ideal he wasn't just
going to leave the baby behind
hiking for three miles with a baby in
his left arm and his m4 on his right
shoulder
he made it back to the jtf camp he
instructed the jtf officer that the
group had been taken care of
and gave the location of the c4
after handing over the baby to the jtf
officer ike was on his way to ann arbor
again
walking through the outskirts of a town
called mackeyville
he saw less than a dozen other people at
this time
midnight in new york he would have had
to be on his toes
coordinating operations through the
chaos and violence happening all around
him
this was actually the time he was first
contacted by mantis
she was the voice of a new rising power
they saw how the current government was
struggling
but had a new way of getting through
this and achieving a new america
a better america mike lost his
girlfriend and child to the virus
his ex-wife and two other children had
been murdered by the cleaners
in early january the jtf and the
government
were unable to protect them and when
someone had something better to offer
he was all for it he believed in their
goals
but at this stage he knew nothing about
them
as it had been 48 hours since his last
check-in with mantis
he received a call ike updated her on
his position
and what he's been doing to keep up his
cover mantis was also able to provide
some intel
on april's location which confirmed he
was still slightly ahead of her
it wasn't until ike made it to michigan
that he heard from mantis again
she confirmed that april was getting
close to ann arbor and was heading
towards the north campus at the
university of michigan
ike had to get ahead of her and meet up
before she arrived
he needed a chance to gain her trust so
he could find out what intel she had
after arriving in ann arbor ike checked
in with the local jtf outpost
to see if anyone going by her
description had checked in
he was running through the possible
routes she could have been taking to get
there
and eventually settled on the fact that
she was likely to be coming from the
cell
so he set forth to start patrolling the
area
eventually he saw a few people gathering
in the distance
he was a little far away but it looked
like a woman possibly matching april's
description
was being approached by six men and the
situation was quickly escalating
the woman fired her shotgun towards
three of them and started running
but was quickly tackled to the ground if
this was april
he had to act fast without a second
thought
he closed the gap between them and
quickly dispatched the remaining men
april thanks him for saving her life and
explained that she was heading for ann
arbor
ike introduced himself to her and says
that he's heading that way
so we'll join her for the remainder of
the journey
gaining trust from civilians was a
fairly easy task for a division agent
by this stage people recognised and
understood the meaning behind the
glowing orange circle
they walked more than 40 miles to get
there by the end of the day
being that it was late and that they
were exhausted from the day's hike
they decided to get some rest before
visiting the labs in the morning
they found an old rooftop cafe to spend
the night
ike set up a fire pit while april
dragged over an old couch
april was tired and was starting to fall
asleep but was discussing her journey
with ike
who was sitting in a chair on the other
side of the fire when suddenly they both
heard footsteps
another man sporting the orange circular
glow of the division agent
appeared lit up by the light of the fire
the agent introduced himself as aurelio
diaz
mike was concerned by this agent's
sudden appearance
was he aware of what happened back in
manhattan where he was forced to leave
civilians behind
in a firefight but before he could pry
into diaz's reason for being there
april started telling the story of how
she and ike met on the road to ann arbor
she then went on to tell them the full
reason of why she was making this
journey
and about the broad spectrum antivirals
that were being produced in the labs
she was to visit the next day so that
was it
ike thought this was the reason mantis
had him following her
mantis in an organization would need
these antivirals if they were to build
this new america
i could work early just before dawn he
was half expecting april and diaz to be
gone
but she was still asleep on the couch
and diaz was standing up
leaning against the deck railing
ike had the urge to explain his actions
in manhattan but he knew he had no way
of making him understand
let alone the reasons behind his
allegiance towards mantis organization
but ike still felt he had made the right
decision
the jtf were incapable of looking after
the people in their care
and if there was truly a cure to the
dollar flu it should be handled by
people who know what they are doing
ike excused himself to go to the
bathroom it had nearly been 48 hours
since his last contact with mantis
when he was out of earshot from diaz in
april he called in
watching the stairway behind him ike
told mantis of what he had learned
that there is an antiviral being worked
on at the north campus
mantis confirmed and said that there is
a team on route to extract him
and the product but ike knew he couldn't
risk exposure at this moment
they only had one shot at this he told
her to hold off until he'd seen the
product with his own eyes
instead the team should move into place
outside of ann arbor and execute once
he'd confirmed
the three of them made their way to the
labs and managed to find one of the
professors in charge
she confirmed she had worked in a team
with bill kelleher april's husband
she went on to tell them how shortly
after the outbreak officials placed
priority on keeping the facility secure
so they could continue their work they
managed to create a batch
composed of 24 doses of the antivirals
and that they had been sent to an
advisor of the president
in washington dc it was at that moment
that agent diaz
had received a call in his earpiece and
went out into the hall to answer it
while april continued to get answers to
her questions relating to her husband
after a few minutes diaz returned then
casually he pivoted towards ike
and knocked him out cold with a left
hook
while tying him to a chair he would go
on to explain why
diaz tells april the full story that ike
was an agent
stationed in new york and he had left
three days after april had under orders
from an unknown organization
that he is a double agent that he has
gone rogue
he was under specific orders to find
april and that he has been tracking him
ever since he abandoned civilians in new
york
leaving them to die the call he just
received told him that ike had just
ordered a strike on this facility
and that they will be here any minute
this caused the professor to run from
the room
so she could inform the local jtf who
were guarding the compound
ike started to come too he explained how
he was approached by a group
how they confirmed what he was already
feeling at the time that the government
and the jtf were incapable of restoring
order to the country
that it was time for someone else to
step in and fix things
it was about this time that they could
hear the sound of helicopters
approaching
ike went on to say that they better move
fast a couple of weeks from now they'll
be seizing control of the fuel supplies
up and down the east coast as whoever
controls the fuel
controls the vehicles and it would be
the vehicles that would decide the
outcome of the upcoming war
leaving ike tight to the chair dears in
april evacuated the building
attempting to find a way of escaping the
facility
with blackhawks approaching it was
obvious that the jtf had no chance of
holding off this attack
they were outnumbered and outgunned
and this is the last we hear of icronson
in case you hadn't guessed it by now
this story is heavily based on the
broken door novel
which is the sequel to the new york
collapse
if you haven't read either of these
books i strongly urge you to
they're fantastic and they really go
into the details of what happened
and what it was like during the early
stages of the outbreak
they're a really cool addition to the
story with depth that cannot be found
anywhere else
these videos are really just scratching
the surface
if you're new to the channel i have a
number of other videos on april's story
i'll link these in the description if i
didn't think i was going to get striked
in some way i'd probably make some sort
of audio book series on the novels
but i'm not really sure of the legality
around that sort of thing anyway thank
you very much for watching i hope you've
enjoyed this
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers
[Music]
foreign